التسرب المدرسي شبح يخطف الاطفال من مقاعد
المدرسه وينقلهم الى سوق العمل مبكرا جدا
ظاهره تتوحش بمرور الوقت وتعاني منها عدد
من الدول العربيه ومصر من اكبر المتضررين
الحكومه المصريه يبدو انها قررت ان ترفع
رايه الحرب عبر تشريع جديد يعاقب اولياء
الامور الذين يقررون سحب ابنائهم من
المدرسه وعدم استكمال تعليمهم مشروع
القانون الجديد الصحه عنه رضا حجازي وزير
التربيه والتعليم المصري امام البرلمان
لكنه لم يحدد ماهيه العقوبات المفروضه على
الاسر مع وجوده الدعم الحكوميه للاسر
بماده التزام ابنائهم في الدراسه الخطه
تقضي باحتواء معدلات الاميه المرتفعه
ومحاصره الجهل عند ارباب الاسر في
المستقبل بخلاف الحد من زواج القصيره
[موسيقى]
الحكومه المصريه لم تخفي فرض عقوبات صارمه
ومشدده على الاهالي الذين يتسببون بتسرب
اولادهم المدرسه ويجبرون اولادهم على ترك
مقاعد الدراسه من الناحيه القانونيه ما هي
هذه العقوبات ما طبيعتها
هو حاله من حالات التعرض للخطر
العقاب المباشر على هذه الحلقه فقط في
القانون القديم لم يكن هناك عقاب
بالحبسه او الغرامه
المشروع الجديد هو اا اذا تسرب الطفل وكان
سبب هي الاسره
يبقى تفرض عقوبه على المتسبب في هذا
التصرف همم ست شهور حبس او الغرامه وهنا
القاضي يحدد همم مدى اا المتسبب والظروف
والملابسات وبناء عليه بيصدر الحكم
المناسب همم من الممكن ان تشدد العقوبه
القانون بياكد على اذا كان المتسبب هو
اللقائم على تربيه الطفل سواء اذا كان
مثلا الاسره او وجد مثلا في دار من دور
الرعايه والقائم عليها وهو كان السبب في
التسربه من التعليم تشدد العقوبه لتصل الى
سنه حبس او الغرامه طبعا وهنا ده بياكد
على مدى حمايه الطفل بشكل كبير من همم
طبعا الخطوره اللي ممكن تنتج على انتصارهم
من التعليم ده غير ان التسرب من التعليم
هيحرمه من التعليم ده في حد ذاته جريمه
المصري وفق التعدين